vitalik the guy that created ethereum oh
yeah got posted on the front of time i'm
gonna [ __ ] need some carbs
i got too skinny he looked like the
pianist actually she's being honest real
talk oh machinist looking ass man post
it on the cover of time here i'll pull
up the actual cover but basically
everyone just started trolling them
calling him uh tom brady how is that
trolling him that's the biggest
compliment he's ever gotten like it's
not just tom brady they're like you look
like tom brady with aids tom brady with
zika maybe i mean loki
he doesn't look like
like
copper
he
brady yeah yo
that's crazy this is crazy dude like
people were trolling them heavy and they
were just like you were like tom brady
on dialysis like going off oh my god bro
he does look like tom brady with eight
philadelphia yeah
and then this is like all like the
tweets like i've never seen someone
deserving of being shoved in a locker
[Laughter]
like clone tom brady locked him in his
basement
all this [ __ ] uh if tom brady was on dog
food
is it possible to be this rich and still
be this ugly get a transplant or a
wardrobe that's just mean
crazy and that's cruel he screenshots
all these and then shares them and says
the quote tweets on the new time article
about me are truly amazing these are
barely even cherry-picked it's pretty
much one piece of awesome content after
another highly recommend scrolling and
then he goes on to say i don't even know
who tom brady is
oh shut up i had to ask people around me
my best guess is that he was an actor
from mission impossible
they he thought it was tom cruise
that's cat this is him trying to get on
top but like that [ __ ] killed him he's
not from america
so
bless you thank you
this is this is him trying to like
this is him doing uh what is it owning
it
tom brady who
like is that yeah he knows who the [ __ ]
it is he tried to own everybody making
fun of him by retweeting it but then his
ego still wouldn't allow it to happen so
he goes well i don't even know who tom
brady is [ __ ] you know who tom
brady is yeah yeah you know exactly who
tom brady is like
get the [ __ ] out but then tom brady
responded and said what's up vitalik you
may not know me but just want to say i'm
a big fan of yours thank you for
everything you've built it's not tom
brady dude all right
autograph his uh like crypto nfc company
wouldn't have been possible hope i get
to meet you someday you're the goat
wow
he's so smart dude
what's the best way to play that if
you're tom brady and you're already the
alpha the situation yeah just be humble
yeah no even if he's fake humble he's
doing it to make money he goes yo thank
you so much vitalik on these virals
there's humility yeah
and then goes yo also check out
autograph if i'm vitalik i repost every
single one of them and i just do crying
emojis
that's it you don't have to do any more
i don't even know what tom brady is or
just be like oh my god i look like tom
brady that's it
he might not actually even if you didn't
know you don't say it you know who tom
brady yeah like he's caught in this
bubble where he's like the and everybody
in that bubble is going oh my god you're
a genius you created this like you know
world-changing technology only you are
truly the chosen one of crypto and he's
doing this time magazine thing where he
gets to feel like he is and finally he's
gonna get all this mainstream love and
support he's not gonna be this little
weirdo that does get shoved into lockers
not gonna be this weirdo that's gonna be
ignored by women constantly he's not
gonna be this little weirdo and then the
internet was like
you're a weirdo
football is just so american
he's lives in america yeah i know now
but like how long you need to live in
america did not know about thomas live
in america actually yes he got the peter
thiel grant that's what he used it for
to build ethereum yeah
i didn't know he actually lives in
america i don't know he's a russian did
so he's here and he ain't in russia
that's a fact but who's like the biggest
cricket player
it's like i don't know if people said i
look like the biggest freaking player we
don't need to know it's the third world
they have to know about us we don't have
to know about them okay
i'm being serious they play it in
english everyone knows who lebron james
is everyone knows i think basketball is
bigger than football globally tom brady
is bigger than football that's probably
true like this guy exists on the
internet we know who ronaldo is yeah i
mean soccer is a global sport
is it is it not here though
not here but it's big it's bigger here
than i think football is [ __ ] this is
this is the globe all right
like
america what are you talking about
everything else is like yeah but like
islands i don't expect them to know
tom brady in russia say again i don't
expect them to know tom brady in rome
they know tom brady
i guarantee he's on advertisements in
russia yeah but if you're a dude that's
creating literally
mark you're on reddit he already you've
seen me live here i don't know if he
does he lives here
he lives here where
he lives in miami
he lives in miami or silicon valley yeah
san fran 100
that's where he got that absolutely
okay
no he lives in
toronto say again he lives in trump and
he knows who tom brady is i don't know i
don't know about god
even if he doesn't
he then finds out that he didn't know
who he was yeah oh this is the greatest
football player ever that's my point he
doesn't have to say it exactly but he
said it because his ego was hurt that's
probably true because he he knows deep
down that he's a nerd
but he's insulated with all these
compliments so he stops thinking he is
one and all these [ __ ] are around and
they're like oh my god we love you we
love crypto because you're a billionaire
no
this is what it is your aid's tom brady
your aides
you look like aids
five he does okay but he can fix that he
can eat and he's choosing not to do it
and that's what bothers me bezos glowdo
and soda elon yeah and it's not even
glow up do you like pasta enjoy it
i'm trying to glow down okay i've done
glowed up too much you look good on the
shirt with the shirt yeah you look fire
all i'm saying is this kid all he has to
do is drink diet coke drink coke
have a slurpee have ice cream literally
enjoy life
all he has to do is enjoy life and he'll
look like [ __ ] tom brady
he'll look like
one of the greatest white men in history
i agree with that he's a milkshake away
from looking like one of the greatest
white men in history
maybe these guys tb12 real talk get on
tv 12 avocado ice cream do whatever the
[ __ ] you got to do
come on bro
tom brady greatest white man ever ever
ever hmm okay
jesus white
no
no he's not
okay i don't name it name a better white
guy name one
uh george washington no no he owns
slaves that's tom brady's probably you
don't know that
yeah it's probably his [ __ ] wife not
want to do nothing
okay but he still had a happiness
abraham lincoln
who showed more black people the
promised land tom brady abraham lincoln
i say tom brady abraham lincoln son
abraham got taken out son like that's
corny yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah tom brady tom brady still got
some time though
geez okay he does technically
yeah you're right speaking technically
okay yeah i think abraham lincoln